foreign please please tell me that this
is an actual match please tell me this
isn't that much we're not getting
trolled khan is going for the mod okay
guys i don't think i can take it anymore
check it out we're in italy bellissimo
xyz whatever let's get into it guys
please i don't have any more sunglasses
to rip off okay no this is the match
let's go yes um by the way my prediction
is i like belong to one two or three one
sorry okay all right
yes i
think i i feel like bella's just
chilling at home playing and if he is
he's going to play with all the
confidence in the world
yeah
also arduino character
martic is a character that the law
specifically said before in the past
that
he knows how to fight against he knows
the matchup and he knows how to optimize
but hey you can't really optimize it for
getting jungled right
yeah yeah
absolutely my monarch is still one of
them characters man no matter how good
you are against the character you still
have to deal with the damage
and the mix-ups look at that car taking
the first round
round yeah that's unfortunate of course
he had the rage he had the rage art
and he's got the launch could have gone
either way that opening round but below
right now standing with the second knee
yep and you mention it yourself mark
just now that bilal said he's very
confident versus marduk but you know if
he ever played against the john it would
always be a
very very easy match for him in the
first attempt but this is a different
monarch this is this is fake con
yeah and sometimes that's the trap too
you get into that chapter like i play
against john i beat him convincedly i
can take on any mark but not every mark
is the same that's i think
the trap that a lot of people fall for
they get used to tendencies from other
players and sometimes it doesn't carry
over click that two round street
yeah
playing very solidly haircut
[Music]
it's a longer set maybe this is the
static maybe this is the interruption
that khan was going for is to kind of
confuse below like hey
i'm not the john i'm the con yeah
and yeah right now he's running him over
right now bella hasn't been able to get
anything started
khan just shutting him down the defense
i'll point the down forward one to catch
him
that's a good down forward one by the
way that is one of the best launching
uppercut moves in the game
what can he do
orbital is not working out
orbital is not working out
he wasn't able to really get comfortable
he wasn't able to get comfortable and
catch up to khan's timing at all right
you saw that the whiffed orbitals and
the four threes they weren't counter
hitting he wasn't getting anything
started um but hopefully bilal has been
able to download a little bit of
information there on the way that khan
is playing he was a lot more aggressive
with mark than we used to seeing him
play with geez for example and even
negan so um he'll definitely make some
adaptation moving into this next match
but khan wow i mean it just goes to show
that if you have solid fundamentals you
can pick up any character and just make
it work
oh yeah and it helps that marduk is one
of those characters he's he's a cheap
ass character he's a good character
not a cheap ass character he's a very
good character um
the fear of his tools sometimes is
enough to overwhelm opponents just the
fear of them he didn't even tackle bro
he didn't even
need it he didn't need it yeah exactly
and and it's like you mentioned yourself
with downford one it was a move which
tracked to his weak side and it was 16
frames i believe in tag two but now it
attracts both sides and i think it's 15
now too so it's like they buffed it a
lot in this game um not only that it's
like a little bit okie tool from some of
his throws it's so crazy
the old key right so i believe that
marduk and ling are the two characters
that have the best op in the game i
don't think there's anyone that not that
no no not that anyone doesn't come close
but those two are clearly for me one and
two i don't know which one but they both
have things they have real okie they
have real loki because a lot of okie in
this game can be solved by rolling back
or holding back as you get up off the
ground or rolling to one way with those
characters because of the options that
they hold link can reset people into
different positions marduk has the scary
ground throw that you have to deal with
there's
different layers of mix-ups that you
have to deal with when fighting those
characters and marduk in particular
if you guessed wrong that's the thing is
you can't react to it if you guessed
wrong you're in a world of hurt
and you have a uh
you can force it
we have a um a modic player from ireland
called john it's funny he's actually
called john yeah
and he's actually the i would say he's
the best mark in europe but he doesn't
compete right um so those who know him
you know him and his oki with this cat
with marduk he knows the oaky inside out
better than probably any mark in the
world that i know of and you i i've
really got to see just how strong
this man's uh how strong the marx oaky
can actually be that after everything
you're guessing for your life you know
what i mean and and i'm not saying that
all the other marks in the world don't
do and he does it but like
you you'll see that even if it's not
optimized there are still certain people
who um if you play marduk you'll know
the certain situation you set it
yourself down forward one backward catch
launching there's so many situations
where if you backfall you're dead uh and
then if you don't back off throw on the
floor or mix up it's just crazy man it's
it's a very oppressive character
layers of fear and that's like i think
one of the things that marta kind of
helps it's still against his opponent at
least from the okazemi standpoint
but again we are getting ready for our
next match right now it's khan he's up
1-0 versus bilal bilal has to make some
adjustments here uh previously
uh i thought bilal was super ready for
marduk you know he's he's preached about
that in the past that marduk is not a
problem for him he's shown it as well
playing against the best martin player
arguably with the jon
dominating him in different sets when
they played together offline but um in
this particular instance he he got he
got brushed aside he got brushed aside
so will we see adjustments i don't know
that's the question yeah yeah exactly so
you mention yourself it's a different
player it's a different dynamic it's a
different pacing it's it's like
different mind games so
um let's see what bulla chooses to do
here what stage is he gonna go to he'll
be sticking with the brian most likely
mishima dojo here we go
no crazy walls here
we've got a conventionally shaped stage
and bellar would be looking to make the
comeback here
adaptation is all going to be about
timing because that's what it comes to
when it comes to high level second let's
go second game
oh my god speaking of timing let me just
throw it out down one plus two to start
it gets the wall yeah nasty oh my god
oh my god
oh no
um
that was that was a lot to take in at
the start by the way that was a lot
yeah i mean look at the damage man
all right bilal's working on the come
back oh my gosh that's going to hurt
nice
careful for the rage
oh
oh he knew
oh
god is so good to come back there the
defensive on point
fight he almost had him though
almost had to come back
kind of switching it up now playing a
bit more defensively not trying to run
into any of those
crushes or hits
and remember guys these guys know each
other very very well the person that
bilal went to after he lost that first
set versus ak at the lcq in thailand it
was khan khan was the one who gave him
the coaching that allowed below to make
the comeback these guys know each other
very very well
nice gets the one down two trying to
continue good two three to punish one
again a low parry kill
he's gonna get the wall again this is
gonna hurt
he has big legs big hips
oh no oh my goodness he's gonna have to
be careful
look at the defense mark look at the
defense come on jesus
wow
i am without words right now i i do not
know what to say this is quite the
dominant performance here
khan
confident going into this right
he picked marta he knew what he was
going to do going into the matchup and
it's working whatever his plan was is
working to a t
yeah man it's uh you've got a game plan
here like i said this is the person that
um back in tekken you can see the
picture as well it was taken below he
took a lot of time in between that's
that grand final step between with ak
and he had to go speak to his coach he
said he you know he had arslan there he
had khan there he was only allowed one
person to give him coaching and he said
to us i'm sorry but i need to talk to
khan khan what do i do i gave him the
advice he said look this is what you
need to do i know you as a player i know
how you are this is what you need to do
in order to win
below went back on stage and took it six
rounds or nine rounds two to one
khan knows bella very well not just as a
player but either they've traveled
together everywhere they went to that
they they all the big tournaments they
travel together they must play together
all the time
between the two do you know i think khan
i think khan is older yeah um sometimes
when it's that senpai kohai relationship
it's sometimes it's hard to overcome
that yeah i don't know if you guys are
pay attention like anime weeb culture
and stuff like that but sometimes it's
just you know the senior player
is always the senior player and maybe
that's what's coming into play there
maybe there's that level of confidence
but man six rounds straight that's
that's kind of crazy
i mean there's something about bella's
play style that khan has definitely um
you know uh definitely downloaded or he
knows who he knows about and he's
decided to surprise him
those two key moments in that in that
second match he low paired he knew at
the end of the round went to low perry
it's the thing it's we talked about
timing again timing is the most
important but he knew exactly when he
was going to go for it and he got the
kill
and
that wasn't a coincidence each time he
knew
yeah he knew
this this might be coming as a surprise
to a lot of people because khan hasn't
been the guy that's been in the grand
finals or the top threes of these major
tournaments when they've traveled when
you see arslan on balala tournament khan
is usually there with them too and
you haven't seen khan do the same when
it's with the tournament performances
that doesn't mean that he's not an
insane player he's beaten some of the
best players in the world um it's just
about being able to compose yourself in
tournament and you know get yourself
ready for the first two and and adapt
really quickly right and it's something
that she's doing really well hey he
knows these players mostly players that
i entered today they were indian and
pakistani so a lot of these guys he
might already have knowledge about uh
bilal being one of them so he's in the
position right now one match away making
to grand finals on the winner's side and
then from there i don't know if there's
anyone that's going to be able to take
him out
all right of course we are going to wait
for this pivotal third uh maybe last
match here in this race to three right
now khan is up
two
to zero
very interesting
i don't know what bill does now you know
i'm not sure what he does does he go for
uh
does he go for a bob does he go for a
brian or did he stick with the bright i
don't know like it's going to be tough
let's have a look at the the bracket
just to show you where we're at right
now
uh khan up uh 2-0 and if he wins this
next match he will move into the grand
finals on the winner's side all to play
for bella needs to make a three match
comeback if he loses he'll be going to
the loser final where he'll play either
against the dark prince or fgl to the
newer
two of the newer um players that have
definitely uh caused a lot of upsets
today and
had a great performance so
this top four is looking very spicy
very spicy indeed and we still have fgl
versus dark prince kind of as you
mentioned uh darkmoon's being one of the
surprises for me here in the tournament
here obviously i knew about his combo
videos in the past and the content that
he's made but i did not know he could
bang them out like that in tournament
play it's nice to see great stuff from
what i've seen so far i got it you're
from just because i love seeing high
level mishima play
which yeah from what you told me mishima
play in pakistan is actually pretty rare
right just they don't really use mashima
characters right
no they don't and it's it's um i don't
know if it was someone telling me that
it was because of the arcade sticks they
had there if you look at the arcade
sticks they have in in pakistan i don't
think that they were suited
um
for mishima play and now with of course
the introduction of all the different
arcade sticks you can buy and you know
enforcement over and stuff and uh it's a
lot easier to do so but i guess i i'm
not sure maybe i'm i'm saying something
wrong here but uh i was told that it was
uh maybe a little bit hard to to play
mishamas with the sticks that they used
to use in the arcade cabinets back in
pakistan and back in the day so having
um
there was no kind of a history of of
mishima players like um korea would have
or like south america would have um but
these newer guys coming up and and like
that dark prince and and arbit uh these
uh rajputs these guys are you know
putting missions back on the map and of
course
some of the strongest characters in the
game so why wouldn't you right if you're
fundamentally solid uh put it put in
some time with these mishimas and you
can see the reward you get man dark
darker prince man this guy is
this guy's execution is on point man
most of the time he's getting these uh
perfect electrics he's getting big
damage and he's here in top four because
of it man he's been rewarded
we're just waiting on this uh this last
this last match to just the startup
potential last match
uh bilal versus khan a surprise pick
from khan going for the marduk we were
used to him playing um
negan uh and uh shaheen jin and geese
but he has brought out the marduk here
and it has been six rounds straight this
is not what uh bilal would have uh
expected
uh at all like definitely not definitely
not what he expected
all right guys all right we are getting
ready for the matchup thanks guys for
tuning in i appreciate you guys spending
some of your time out of your day to
spend with us here for the tekken online
challenge we are focused here on the
south asia region right now we are going
into our third match here in our winter
side finals between fate khan and asir
villal
right now it's marduk on fake khan's
side but allah sticking to the brian
fury back to the mashima dojo he has a
deficit he has to win three straight
matches here he cannot switch any more
characters
all right all right here we go here we
go
back to the mishima dojo let's see if
you are commanders come back
oh and pokemon right now the gates ready
for the world
that down forward one on point good
break there on the ground
let's see how he deals with that orbital
yeah
hey hey
have the
wall you trying to catch him
good adjustment there
he does he trades
oh boy oh no wow damage okay i don't
think he was ready for that get up
ladies and lads that is seven rounds
straight now for khan against villal
is it looking very very bleak for below
right now
oh nice step
able to get that forward for the follow
up here let's see what he does
back force
oh gosh that hurts
have you tall frame punish man
i know and having the ability to do it
out of crouch so quickly too is so crazy
yeah
hey nice gets the tackle to follow up
here no pun is here on the wall 73
see what he does back one able to land
able to hit oh back dashing to the rape
drive
oh no
wow the pop-up kick saved his life
careful oh nice
recharge
yeah he finally got around to which is
important he had to break the street
eventually yeah yes again self-hype
somehow man oh god that hurts
how's he gonna deal with it the pressure
he knew the moment he was able to come
in
[Music]
launcher below
ow
it's looking sloppy now from below
on the back foot
khan is gonna move into the grand finals
taking it over below three to zero
what a performance with the marduk a
surprise pick by him
the lavo still alive in the tournament
he will be moving to losers finals but
man that was uh a bit of a beat